hello i hope you enjoyed our most recent
season of worth it
season eight we're currently working on
some new episodes of the show but in the
meantime
we thought it'd be fun to look back at
some old ones coincidentally
it happens to be almost three years
exactly since we released our three-part
series in australia
there's a lot of threes in that sentence
australia had some of the best food i've
ever had
tasmanian beef wagyu finger limes
freshwater marin it was quite a journey
so here's a marathon of all three
episodes you can watch them all at once
get the full experience
please enjoy ladies and gentlemen
the next time you see us we will be
in australia underwhelming australia
you ready mates that's what that's what
they say in australia right
mate and stuff seafood we're gonna go
eat some seafood now
shellfish and chocolate today in wars in
australia part one
we are going to try three different
seafood dishes at three drastically
different price points to find out which
one and what's worth it at its price
seafoods
are my favorite foods are they really
you know how you can have like more than
one favorite kid i've never had kids so
i can't
really speak to that yeah me neither we
are on our way to
the sydney fish market it is going to be
epic part about it i haven't been there
yet you just googled pictures i mean
people just google our show
to find out about seafood same thing
there is a pelican right outside our car
it's beautiful
already let's go pelican
[Music]
oh i get it now
ocean trout that one fish head no
touching
[Music]
the large coral trout blue crabs
orange collabs the cutest fish
the cuttlefish let me see those prawns
hi my name is you are doyle's here we
have different kinds of oysters specific
in city rock
whatever you want you can try it over
here so you guys are sourcing these
specific oysters from
literally the place that is on the sign
right yeah they are like dealers that we
get the oysters from not all the lot
taste the same
if they are from the different harvest
when the new lot comes i try it so i'm
better confident so i can explain to the
customer what it actually tastes like
coffin base pacific oysters well salty
oysters sydney rock they are more of a
strong flavor creamy and sweet creamy
and sweet sounds
nice yeah the truth is that i have my
watches a year and a half ago
the first that i tried i really didn't
like it but gradually
i loved it and right now i'm addicted to
oysters you don't get the texture and
the flavor of oyster anywhere else and
there
are people that really love oysters like
when i
give them oysters and their facial
expressions you know you know like
they're really enjoying it it makes me
happy to see them happy as well so how
many are going to get you want to get uh
let me just get two of each who eats one
oyster
well we're gonna eat one of many
different kinds am i crazy yes you're
crazy we should get one for uh adam as
well though all right
i have never been more excited in my
life than this moment i have to confess
i haven't been won over yet wait
seriously yeah seriously
that makes me so sad though oysters are
so good i know and i'm trying really
hard but they
are just snot rocks let's uh chuck these
oysters we're gonna start with the
coffin bay twist it and uh shave it
inside
the sides and then uh voila let's see
who does it better
well pat now that just doesn't look
fabulous cheers to sydney
[Music]
oh yeah that is the saltiest oyster i've
ever had i'm not
disgusted it just you know it became one
with me i mean when you're doing an
episode about seafood that is
as pure a taste of the sea as i think
we're gonna get you wanna go with the uh
sydney rock now i'm very curious to see
the differences between these
that's the funnest part about eating
oysters is you get these tight little
packages
and each one is going to be a little bit
different that is
very pretty ugly ugly delicious that's
what uh
david chang said
[Music]
that was like a delicate cheese imagine
a world where humans have not
ruined the world with our smog and ocean
beach amazing waves and that
fresh breeze of air that is that oyster
perfection
i could eat a dozen of those and that's
the first time i've ever thought that
about an
oyster you're an ultra boy now i think i
might be an oyster boy now
birds are going hammers you know what's
up they're oyster boys too
that was crazy i've had a lot of oysters
in my life
the american ones don't send a chance at
this i'm sorry
that was easily my favorite location
food
anything that we've ever done in the
show australian seafood bag
oh dear don't do that did you know that
the
australian seafood industry is about 2.8
billion
with a b with a b for big ones
just by looking at a atlas of the world
you know that australia
is getting some great fish so we're on
the way to
the next location which i cannot imagine
can come
close to that kind of experience that we
just had but wow
as is the premise of the show
my name is brent savage i'm chef owner
of cirrus restaurant
serious for us is all about seafood what
we wanted to serve as syrus in our minds
it was always to be simple it was to be
accessible it was to be sustainable
and not add too many flavours so it
brings out the best in each piece
today's dish that we're going to have is
it's live marine forgive me but what is
a meringue so marin is australian fresh
water crayfish the flavour of marin is
actually quite strong so it can
tolerate other flavors with it we're
going to split the marinade in half
we're going to clean out the head
fill it with a little bit of marin
butter which we've made from the shells
of marin place a little bit of salt over
it
simply cook it over the charcoal i don't
like cooking just about anything in
water
all water really does is reduce the
amount of flavor bring it off the heat
let the residual heat slowly cook the
remainder of the flesh through
we're gonna serve it with a yuzu koshi
sauce music kosher
is a type of ferment we have the native
herbs which is sort of burst of
saltiness we're finishing the dish with
a little bit of finger lime
finger lime is an ingredient which is
native to australia so you've got layers
of the sweet meat sour from the finger
lime salty from the herbs it's
quite a delicious dish so we started the
day off a little casual
but now we're getting a little serious
that's probably
the best pond you've ever done okay so
no way
so we're having some australian marin
we're having some australian garnishes
also having some australian wine
do you like it i can't tell if you like
it or not i like it a lot it's really
strong
this is the most excited i've ever been
for a dish plating
garnishes meat beauty it's just
everything
that is delightful in a moment i'm gonna
like
i'm gonna cry this is far superior meat
to lobster maybe it's not quite as
tender
but the flavor flavor yeah oh yeah it is
so good you want the marin flavor and
they doubled up on it you can really
see it come through the little pearls of
the finger lime
are next level because you don't taste
it
until they burst in your mouth i don't
want to finish this because they just
don't want this to end
you got some meat loves over here i mean
wait that's that's for adam
yeah stop that's for adam look at you
you don't think about our
crew our people we can get him his own
whatever
right that was mad good double
marinated marin surprise facts
here's a fact that i got interested in
while eating at cirrus
and i took the time to google it just
now lobsters and other shellfish
like the crayfish we just had start one
color
and then turn another when they're
cooked that's because there are a bunch
of different pigments
in the shell of a lobster but there's
one that's called
astex and thin a sexanthin that is the
only one that's stable in heat you think
if we uh
threw you in a boiler what color would
you think would come out it would just
be a burst of light that would sear your
retinas
name as many cities as you can in
australia
go perth darwin sydney brisbane
melbourne uh alice springs
i also know where we're going because
this trip was planned far in advance
it is melbourne by the power of movie
magic you will not have to sit with us
for the next
five hours unfortunately i will
[Music]
it's cold melbourne melbourne
melbourne melbourne melbourne melbourne
we're in melbourne so we're on our way
right now to the last even spot what is
happening
i'm bernard i'm the cheffy cuisine in
south melbourne sils is a
more of a traditional cantonese cooking
restaurant today we're going to
introduce the raised green lip baloney
green lip abalone is one of the most
luxurious item you can eat because how
it's caught it's hand dives they're
actually harvested about 40 meters down
the sea on reefs and yeah it's a luxury
item the most luxurious seafood you can
get
how much is it to order here it can be a
bit pricey it's 178
per hundred grams do we request like i
want one kilogram or i want 100 grams
that's correct usually a lot of people
come in and they
they have a sharing if you're gonna have
that for the entree it's a lot to have
and how would you describe the flavor of
abalone i would say
very seafoody it's flavoursome it's a
whole mouthful
we received a live abalone from our one
of our suppliers we shut them and then
we clean off the guards we clean off the
skirtings after the abalone has been
blanched we fill it in the bag with the
stock
with oyster sauce and chinese wine i
know the traditional way people doing it
they need to put their baloney straight
in the pot but what we've realized is
that it loses its shape so what we do is
we actually souvent slow cook it so it
maintains its shape in the flavor
in its own juice so it's double the
flavor we serve it actually with
a japanese mushroom served with two bok
choy very simple
very simple very classic but it's very
flavorful
what what is this this is the mongolian
tent at silks it's usually not for two
people
but uh i had to do it i feel like i'm at
a chinese new year dinner
now we've flown all the way to melbourne
to try
the green lit abalone and this is how
gold should be served in a subtle
classic way i like how you now have
preferences on how gold should be served
on your food it is awesome that this is
dived for by hand 40 meters down you
basically have to be
the ocean version of an astronaut to do
that so a scuba diver
it smells so good it smells rich cheers
wow wow
wow that's pretty good ah really good it
has a very satisfying texture
it's both firm but supple simple that's
like if you took
a scallop and an oyster and you combine
the flavors together
it is crazy that you have this just
solid
blob of deliciousness yeah how often
else does that happen in nature
shout out to nature i am so contented
we're in a tent video over
i just love seafood so good we had three
seafood dishes at
two cities which seafood was the most
worth it to you at its given price
here's the deal i had the best oyster
i've ever had
at doyle's oyster bar at the sydney fish
market i didn't think oysters could be
that good
but cirrus the grilled marin worth it
winner that was
really one of the best sea creature
eating experiences i've ever had my arm
is tired can you hold this
my turn so the abalone was quite a steep
price although it was
definitely worth the experience sydney
fish market i thought for sure that was
going to be that worth a winter going in
but all that being said
sirius is also my worth at winner today
i mean come on that
place was ridiculous adam what's your
worth at winter
[Music]
nice what's it called worth it with
three-way a worth of no no
no no three-way worth it winner does it
yeah for part one we're here in
australia we got more coming in we're
gonna do wine
we're gonna do steak
where is it melbourne we're actually
leaving melbourne now we are on our way
to
the wine regions of victoria victoria
goodbye to the city second
one
we are now in part two of a three-part
series where the work is hungry boys
well today we're thirsty boys taking on
off
today on worth and wine australia
edition we're gonna be trying three
bottles of wine at three drastically
different price points to find out which
wine is the most worth it at its price
so i did some more independent research
about australian drinking culture i
learned from our driver sam
an alternative to saying cheers this one
is a little bit more of a thinker
up yours that's not a thinker it's
a stinker
my name is aleister perbrick i'm a
fourth generation winemaker we're
standing in the tubulc winery which
began its operations back in 1860 today
we're going to be talking about massan
and in particular 2016 vintage we have a
hundred acres which is the largest
single holding in the world
we make our marsan differently to most
in that it is stainless steel fermented
the critical factor
is about excluding oxygen over every
step of the process that's the only way
you'll be able to showcase the diversity
of flavours that the variety has the
wine
enters the bottle under gas cover and
then it just runs around gets labelled
into boxes stacked away ready for sale
in the case over there we saw a spectrum
of more suns that are getting darker as
the bottle is older can you tell us
what is happening with those that's just
the normal oxidative
process the more yellow the closer it is
to its best
as admitted amateur wine tasters what
should we be looking out for
the best way for you to develop your
pellets is to drink a lot of wild
so you've got a very happy future in
front of yourself we're starting off
with the
2016 marsan from the number one marathon
supplier in the world
pale white wines are one of the most
beautiful colors in the natural world
to smell you have to smell wine before
you drink it i'm a seasoned
wine taster look how
fogged up your glasses seasoned my eggs
whatever
honestly halloween candy it's like
starburst
and snickers tell me what you smell i'm
like taking a nap at the beach right
guys coming by with the cart of fruit
the pineapple and the the oranges
and the citrus fruits you want to drink
[Music]
when i pick up a wine that's this color
i'm expecting a
sharpness but this is extremely smooth
words that come to mind
sweet oddly very complex complexly sweet
there's something fun about
tasting wine where it's made i mean
we're in this cool old building it's
almost like you're tasting
history the environment sure i'm gonna
get you a new glass
we were encouraged to actually try the
marathon what it was like in 2010.
in 2010 there were grapes that were
crushed
that turned into this oh there's the
baby how old are you
all righty time travel 2010 here we go
smell it jesus have you learned nothing
whoa that is a drastically different
smell
this is mature that's nice
it's muskier you know what this makes me
think of if you're a kid
you put a rubber band in your mouth if
you reduced all of the acridness
and just had that pure taste you're spot
on with that rubber band it's like a
little
piney like pine coney i bet a rubber
tree
smells and tastes exactly like this one
in a delicious way
i know that sounds crazy it sounds crazy
to you adam come here
that was it was i wrong thank you mellow
fruity delight of a wine and dare i say
truffle it's not truffle slightly
truffley
why in fact grapes native to australia
are not suitable
for wine really the wine industry in
australia actually
comes from immigrants from europe those
people then
export it back to europe
transcontinental trade at its finest wow
that is an interesting wine fact wait do
you want to hear more about that fact
there's more
not really there's more
[Music]
my name's ian firth i'm the chief
storyteller here at fowl's wine what
does that mean
exactly it means that i have absolutely
no qualifications whatsoever
that i am not a winemaker i'm not a bit
of culturalist i just love wine and i
love talking about wine today we're
going to be trying the
ladies who shoot their lunch throughout
the ladies who do their lunch is there a
story behind that there is a story about
that our chief winemaker is an avid
hunter he was eating these meats and
trying to match the right wine to it and
thought there's got to be a wine that's
perfect for game food what specific
foods did you have in mind with these so
at the moment we're matching a venison
with the shiraz with a beetroot radish
you get this wonderful
burst of flavour between the two that
just complement each other really well
thousand wine is located in the
strathbergy ranges there's a cool
climate region now
vineyards are at 500 meters above sea
level it's a very even ripening process
so you get really great ripe fruit but
you maintain some really lovely acid
with the wine
and that's because of the weather you
have in this particular area absolutely
because of that cool environment the
fruit has time to develop these really
intense flavors we
ferment it in stainless steel to start
off with we retain half of that bath
in stainless steel to eat that primary
fruit character
25 percent of the back goes into very
traditional oak barrels so you do get a
lot of new oat
flavor coming in the last 25 we put into
140 year old english car
those three components are then blended
back together to create the final wine
there's some impressive chemistry
happening there
should we try some
[Music]
i can only start this taste test by just
laughing
why because it's the most romantic
setting possible a few glasses of wine
a baguette let's just take a moment and
appreciate this
all right to the boys who drink their
lunch
that's delightful it's gorgeous
a little spaceless right now by just the
wine
the countryside there's a baby over
there hanging out with us what sort of
mouth movement should i do when tasting
a wine for the first time
[Music]
let's taste our wine for real this time
[Music]
that's like a whole other wine okay i
got exactly what that tastes like now
it's fruity
it dances on your tongue it actually
makes you thirstier the more you drink
up yours
this is a dangerous wine wine
is often regarded as a pretentious
beverage
something he knows what i'm talking
about something that's enjoyed
in lounges but this is in fact the
proper setting for wine to be enjoyed
it's not for
dark dining rooms it's for bright crisp
vistas
and the alcohol is definitely there i
can tell you that right now because i'm
feeling
great so here we have venison deer
for the uninitiated with a little
beetroot chutney on top
cheers
damn that is good there we go
oh man that's beautiful oh i love this
it makes wine seem a little bit more
rugged and connected to the earth in a
way that i've never
appreciated before this countryside is a
wonderland
i kind of have a crush on this lady
the boys who drink their lunch wine
facts australia
actually exports more wine to the uk
than france then
really yeah australians seem like they
would share anything with anybody they
made a bunch of wine that's true come
come have it the french on the other
hand
seem like oh i just keep it in my cellar
no one drinks it forever
hey look some cows sheep hold up steven
loves shaving oh not enough space my
phone womp womp
my name is nick i'm a winemaker at all
census dates and one of the owners along
with my two sisters today we're tasting
the museum of muscadill and museum
musket which are both fortified wines
that on average are 100 years old
fortified wine is a wine that's
fortified by spirit in our case neutral
grape spirit so you're adding a stronger
alcohol to a wine that's not done
becoming a wine correct the grapes
they're on the vine right into autumn
where the sugar accumulation is super
high before the yeast gobble up or sugar
and turn into alcohol
we pump in 96 grape spirit which stops
the yeast in our tracks
increases the alcohol to about 18 and
fortifies the wine so the wines we're
tasting today are a blend of different
years but on average it's
100 years old you're actually inheriting
somebody who
had the foresight to barrel up the wine
and let it sit for 100 years
yeah that's right are you presently
creating wine that 100 years in the
future then
also turn into this wine that's kind of
a weird thing to think about isn't it it
is yeah it's a wine that no one will
drink
whilst i'm alive how do you arrive at
the combination of wines that go into
this to
form the blend so there might be 30 or
40 wines lined up we smell and taste
through the wines
and choose the final blend it's such an
amazing complex style of wine one sip
goes a long way so how much is this wine
about a thousand dollars
is a lot of money i know my sisters and
i actually asked our accountant if he
could work out
what the wine costs us to make he came
back with a figure of
twenty thousand dollars a bottle really
why by adding up all the time it's taken
to look after the wine
and my sisters and i said we can't
charge that but um a thousand dollars
should cover
our costs of our yeah imagine a 20 000
new car that you could have for a
thousand dollars yeah we're going to now
try two one thousand dollar wines this
one is the old fence museum muscadell
muscadell is
more aromatic and tastes a bit lighter
i've never experienced that much wine by
just stepping at first it reminded me of
when i discovered
my mother's vanilla extract and i was
like this will be delicious let me set
the scene
you're in harry potter's world okay and
you walk
into a chocolate candy shop yeah and
there's just
all these ridiculously amazing candy on
the wall
this would for sure be dumbledore's
preferred drink
cheers
oh my god oh my god that's extremely
tasty i don't want to sound pretentious
or
like it was the deepest richest grapey
raisin flavor just so razory filling
it's like you had the most delicious
banquet dinner
the moment after your last bite and
you're reminded of all the flavors you
just had it's all of those
in an instant and it has the touch of a
lover
i kind of get what you mean yes yes this
one is the all saints museum muskets
richer and more concentrated and
deceived to be sweeter whoa
this is a step up from the previous one
this is deep
look how steamy you made your glass with
the smelling you're a monster
oh yeah that one was more fragrant this
one's more
intense it's like this labyrinth of
flavors that is why it would be
dumbledore's favorite drink you know
when he pulls the memories out of his
mind
this is like that time warp where you
can just
sample an infinite number of memories
kicking the top of the roof of my mouth
but i don't have taste buds up there
how's that possible i'm having a hard
time coming up with the words to
describe how
powerful and beautiful this is i think
that's important though if it was easier
to explain
it wouldn't be as worth it somebody was
preparing this wine before i was alive
before my mom was alive but they didn't
know
that it would make this and that is the
crazy part i'm still not sure i know
totally what it tastes like but it
tastes like a lot and i'm liking it
it's crazy which wine was the most worth
it at its price for you the more sonic
to build
it's unlike any other white wine i've
ever had fouls
the ladies who shoot their lunch that
was my worth at winter of course
that lady on the bottle got you did she
snipe my heart
perhaps it was just the most delicious
and i really liked the label
and to be honest that's how i picked
most of my wine who's your winner
they were just all so good i think i'm
gonna go
with all saints wine really yes i can't
believe it
i'm not a fancy boy i promise that wine
was born more than a hundred years ago
you can
taste the history that does it for worth
it wine
all's edition
where did that bird go the the cow bird
yeah we're really in australia now
today we're eating steak starting in
sydney adam you excited for steak
what's going on here whoa
i don't think people can appreciate how
great this tree is you certainly can
because you're stupid
all right let's go eat some steak get
your get your saliva rolling today
on worth it australia edition we're
gonna have three steaks at three
drastically different price points to
find out which stake in australia is the
most worth it at its price
remember when we had steak before
will it be surpassed today i'm pretty
sure this is going to be
spectacular spectacular we're actually
arriving right now
look at that hey it's the ocean all
great restaurants are at the ocean oh
my god that's not true good food
is even better
thank you you want to be the host all
righty take my mic here
take it let's go i'll be camera guy for
a day
hi i'm stephen
my name's sebastian lute and we're at
the club valley hotel close to the beach
today we're going to be having a 16
steak that we have on our steak nights
on wednesday it's a piece of rump rum
rum it's part of the meat it's a little
bit tougher near the back of the
shoulder the rum's got a lot more flavor
because it's a mussel that works a bit
more the rum will come in portioned
salt pepper i don't do anything else no
spices or anything on it spit a brush of
bone marrow that we've been melted down
just a bit extra flavors with rosemary
and thyme in it straight onto the top of
the boiler
get a nice char on it both sides then
straight into the boiler
in the middle or about 700 degrees child
out for about two or three minutes both
sides and let it rest
steaks today's gonna be coming with
green beans and match we're both pretty
new to
australian beers these are one you'd
recommend for us to have with this steak
you know what there's a bob hawk one
football used to be an old prime
minister of australia he's got a
reputation for a skull in the fastest b
really the former prime minister yes
here's to the prime minister
of australia that's nice that's
refreshing you know what that is right
there
the rump the wrong oh excellent do you
want to do yours
oh mine's better dog now yours ah
they're both good they're pretty good
mine's just better by default because
it's mine cheers
that's nice that's amazing that that's
just salt
pepper and bone marrow it's also a steak
it adds a lot to the flavor it's a
little bit meatier chewier
it does have that beefier taste that you
get with the rump with the roast cuts so
16 dollars on your fries you got your
beer you got your friends like
what else do you need you want some
that's really good right adam just said
it's really good he just nodded he just
nodded he just went
it's subtle the way that he moves what
are some good australian drinking games
and we're at a pub
i feel like this is the appropriate time
to pop it up yeah
where do we start so there's one with
obviously you get a coin so you choose
heads or tails whatever it lands
you get skull to be if you lose two
dollar coin i call it loser
downs it in the down under
heads what is it gonna be what's it
gonna
let the record show that the coin landed
tails was head look
[Music]
uh-uh that's not going down adam can you
save me here
oh shoot
oh maybe he should be the next prime
minister
it was a tasty steak it was a well done
medium rare steak
oh [ __ ] oh yeah look at that what the
crevice you want to jump it
i saved
[Laughter]
steak facts 70 percent of cattle raised
in australia are grass-fed
who spent their entire life grazing
freely that's a good ratio
right i graze freely i'm happy are you a
free grazer i'm the grey's gatsby
grey's anatomy crazy in love beyonce oh
nice
[Music]
hello my name is kevin donovan i'm the
owner of gentlemen's restaurant along
with my wife gail
wanting to create a relaxed comfortable
environment
on st hilda beach interestingly enough
gail changes the interior accents of the
restaurant every six months she lightens
the colors the restaurant changes the
displays
and people come to the restaurant every
six months say what's new what did they
change everything's
very cozy and i feel i feel very safe
and like
comfortable here and that's exactly what
we're trying to create emma our chef has
been with us for 15 years she's going to
show you how we cook our tasmanian
wilderness beef tea bug my name is emma
d'alessandro and i'm the head chef at
donovan's restaurant here in san kira
and today we're going to cook the
grass-fed british cattle breed
t-bone on the charcoal oven so an order
will come in we pull it out brush it
with a little bit of oil
season it with salt and pepper the
jasper oven that i cook it in
sits at about 350 degrees celsius pop it
in the oven and then we constantly turn
it till it gets a really nice
caramelization crust on it and then i'll
bring it out and i'll rest it so for as
long as i've cooked it i'll rest it for
the same amount of time
when i go to cut it blood's not going to
ooze out all over the plate so you just
get this really nice tender juicy piece
of meat with that you get house cut
chips with rosemary salt and fried
garlic little salad of baby cos leaves
just with a lemon vinaigrette it makes a
complete meal which
is great when you're paying that sort of
price for a piece of meat to the
tasmanian
beef
all right let's eat potato cheers
potato chips
mmm holy crap that is the most potatoy
potato i've ever eaten you want to eat
i do all right let's go oh i went
right through cheers cheers
that awkward moment when you hold your
food chairs for a little too long
this is a great steak look how even that
medium rare is inside that's that bacon
it's familiar in that it's a steak but
it really i don't know it tastes like a
wild
animal oh it's a whole other
experience on the other side of the tea
that bone
meat sorry it's so different the meat
that's right next to the bone that's
what i mean by bone meat it's like
brisket the bone meat the bone meat he
knows what's up look at that bone meat
right there
i'm gonna let adam have some of mine
because it's not as
nod on as yours who's a better dinner
guest how do you know when somebody
enjoys your food when they eat like this
yes sir donovan's right there thought
we'd come out to the beach for just a
moment
that steak made me feel things i've
never felt before
dawling the meat off like a hyena yes
like a tasmanian devil it was that was
tasmanian beef all right here we go
so next up is a steak fact one
two three steak ah
as of june 2017 there was a bill
attempting
to prohibit australian cattle that are
exported from being labeled
as australian beef after they are then
processed in the countries
that import them to be sold oh because
they're not processing it
good enough it doesn't meet
their standards so we're on our way to
the last steak place it's back in sydney
but before we go i have a treat for you
we're gonna go to the farm
where the wagyu was raised let's go meet
some cows
my name is david blackmore i'm the
founder of blackmore wagyu beef this
farm
is a breeding farm the calves are born
here and conceived here
what is wagyu beef wagyu beef is a
japanese breed of cattle a lot of people
think it's a process the japanese have
got this
unbelievable breed of cattle that
produce this unbelievable meat
how the hell did they do it you're
talking about very very accurate
information average daily weight gain
the marbling school
every animal has a different nose print
that was how they've been able to make
sure there was no cheating keep accurate
records
i can do this for probably at least 10
generations on all these cattle that are
behind us we've got an unbelievable
database with over 10 000 animals now
recorded so we can look at that and see
which of our best breeding cows and
which are the best balls that they breed
to
what makes a cow delicious to be honest
a lot of love
and i know that might sound really
really corny but the main thing that can
affect the quality of meat is whether
the cow has been under stress so we
actually monitor everything from prior
to conception right through to the
weaning of the calf and then every other
stage right through as well you know i
like the fact that we can put
flavour into beef and make it something
really different and special do what you
like right and it is i do love what i'm
doing i gotta say
truly this has been the coolest
experience yeah it's been great fun
having you guys here too
my name is corey costello i'm the head
chef here at rockpool bar and grill in
sydney and today you guys are going to
be having two of the david blackmore
wagyu steaks we get a lot of whole
animals in and we break them down into
all the different various cuts but then
we have them all aging up in a room what
is the advantage
of dry aging meat the natural moisture
that's in the meat when you dry age it
intensifies that moisture it's like
reducing a stock down and making it more
flavoursome the first steak you guys
will be eating will be
wagyu i have chuck really really big in
flavor and we actually we never used to
serve it as a steak we used to cut it up
and braise it all the chefs would come
along
and cut off the first cuts of them and
start eating them and eventually i was
like that's it if this is good enough
for all of us to eat it's good enough
for the guests so a new steak was born
our butcher we'll age them anywhere
between 21
up to about 75 days then we very very
lightly sprinkle them with salt a little
bit of oil and then we cook it over a
wood fire grill crust it up onto each
side and then just before the guests are
ready to eat it we give it a little sear
up again and then i slice it on a board
certain steaks have grains that run
through them and we try and cut them out
so that the guest gets the best
experience
that's just for our time in australia
saw cal
sure did
yeah it still gets me the first sip of
wine always still just
the current table setting onion rings
and steak
is child andrew's perfect
table setting don't do it too hard
oh my god wow just straight up fun yet
that's crazy
that's so good all right wait long
enough so this is the eye of the chuck
this is the cut that chefs prefer to eat
when they come to rock wall are you
ready to put this in your mouth who are
you talking to
you oh okay yeah i am cheers
[Music]
i'm just gonna go right back all the
best things in life are done with your
eyes closed
sleeping making out i can't disagree
with that it's
really good oh it tastes like
a beef stock turned into bubble gum it's
reverse bubble gum
it's reverse bubble gum better the more
you chew into it
the next one you have is the grass-fed
sirloin from sort of the middle of the
back of the animal
very high marbles beautiful eating we've
got it for 150
on the menu at the moment so it's a
bargain bargain at 150
targeted 150 it comes with lemon
yeah immediately visualize oh this one
looks
crazy compared to the other sizzle me
with your zest
not literally me look at that marbling
the grain structure is crazy it's like a
comb of meat
cheers to all of australia
that has a very intense flavor i'm blind
don't worry we won't make out it's so
easy to eat i can't slow down and it's
already cut for you i could demolish one
of these in about
five minutes if i was by myself not
trying to be
conscious of other people watching me
there's only salt and lemon on this guy
all the flavor
is baked into the cow i just want to sit
here and enjoy this for the rest of my
life well you can't cause i'm about to
eat it all ready to go home i'm coming
home yeah and with that
we're back in the states back in the
worth it mobile
driving back on the right side of the
road because it's the correct
side or because it's the right side both
all right
so the trip is over but we must now
decide which
stake was the most worth it to you at
its price in australia the clovelly
hotel
at an amazing value state that would be
the perfect
post beach steak do you eat post beach
steaks
pretty beach pre beech steaks the steak
that was most worth it to me
at its price was certainly donovan's
i knew you're gonna say that i mean that
place is
what i would want a restaurant to look
like if i operated it here's what i'll
say about this steak video
every location was amazing but there
must be a winner my winner
goes to rockpool whoa it's not that one
fifty dollar store line it's the
eye chop it's the eye of the chuck it's
the thrill of this day
fight adam what do you think
australians call up here because we call
that down under
are we up over um all right
australia over